[Music]
all right dr anthony factory's latest
flop is college football predictions
remember
right now is where we normally row in
the clip but he said over and over again
he looked at those big crowds he says
essentially in his phil rizzuto delivery
well let's listen
what was your sort of immediate thought
when you saw all of those fans
packed into stadiums in texas wisconsin
and elsewhere as soon as i saw it i
thought kobe's about to have a feast
what did you think i thought the same
thing i think it's really unfortunate i
would hope that most of the people
in that stadium were vaccinated and even
if they were the close congregate
setting they should have been wearing
masks
outdoors two weeks later covet 19 data
is in some of the biggest games were
held and guess what happened nothing the
stands were packed they weren't super
spreaders in fact the rates went down in
those surrounding communities like in
texas despite the university of texas
and texas a m both hosting games
september 4th they drew nearly 190
thousand fans between them the statewide
seven day average currently is lower
than it was on game day hitter react out
kick founder clay travis clay
your reaction
to what the prediction was for dr fauci
as opposed to the reality we're living
in
look all over the south first of all
thanks for having me brian uh millions
of people have gone to college football
games and the number of covet infections
has been plummeting you just referenced
texas same thing has happened in florida
in georgia in alabama in mississippi
all of these states that have had
massive crowds for their college
football games all over the south we are
seeing cases come down meaning when dr
fauci said that he was worried about
super spreader events over these major
college football crowds just flat out
hasn't materialized in fact brian the
opposite has happened the number of
people that are testing positive for
covet all over the south is plummeting
to a massive degree clay think about
this you now have a situation where
china oppresses they are vicious they'll
even let you die and wither away in an
apartment if you're positive and it
still came back then you have permissive
areas and it still comes back and it
goes away might the virus have a say in
how it spreads
that's the big story from the whole
start of this brian i'm not sure that
anything we've done and i look forward
to years from now when all of the
emotion is stripped away and we can
actually look at all of the virology and
all of the epidemiology and the data i'm
not sure that there's going to be
anything that we did at all shutting
down schools sending people home
requiring masks all of it i think it was
mostly cosmetic theater brian i think
the data is going to reflect that the
virus was going to virus people felt
like they needed to do something even
though most of the things that we did
had almost zero impact and some of the
things i mean look at schools the data
on schools when kids go back to school
shows there aren't these super spreader
events when kids go back to school uh
the data is clear that's why many
european countries don't require kids to
wear masks by the way because they also
don't work
but i look forward i think we're going
to see i really do 30 years from now i
think people will look back and say this
was the vietnam war on steroids in this
country 75 percent of the cu of the
eligible uh vaccination population has
gotten at least one shot plus the
natural immunity we're doing a lot
better than anyone thinks meanwhile
what's clicking on out kick
we're getting ready for our bus tour
brian uh we're gonna be in nashville
this weekend for georgia vanderbilt then
we're going down to tuscaloosa for ole
miss alabama and the week after that we
will be in college station texas for
alabama texas a m fantastic crowds
coming out to see us look forward to
seeing people this weekend and can't
wait to be back on the road at some of
these big college football stadiums
where people are going out and living
their lives without fear and it's great
to see people back to normal and clay
travis is working seven days a week for
the last two years you have a lot of
vacation days built up when you get to
your 70s you can actually go fishing uh
clay thanks so much